the big gear 5 episode is just right
around the corner but I have to record
my reactions to it before it happens so
I can post it when it happens so I'm
going to record some separate reactions
good bad or whatever and I'm just going
to make a Frankenstein's monster of it
that applies to whatever ultimately gets
released alright so first off if the
episode is sick I'll probably post
something like oh my god did you see
that that was absolutely incredible like
like they just completely captured the
magic of the manga in the moment and the
animation just heightens it the colors
the drama the spectacle oh my God it was
amazing so if it sucks I'll probably
need to whip one of these bad boys okay
that sucked okay intro the one piece
anime finally released the gear 5 reveal
and my God I'm gonna talk about it today
here was my reaction and soon but what
do you guys think let me know in the
comments down below and there we have it
the perfect ingredients assembles for a
timely review video